this was with my
ex-wife wow yeah ex-wife we're still
friends we're cool shout out xy shout
out xy hover on
on the podcast one day we'll we'll air
our grievances it was a crazy
relationship we were impaired she's
she's british she's from london wales
and we did a whole uh summer of love
thing
crazy kids running around europe
arguing every step of the way
um she likes spending money specifically
she likes spending my money of course so
one of the one of the restaurants we
went to
was the most expensive place in all of
paris called the hotel
costas the hotel pull this off if you
can hotel salt bay
so
c-o-s-t-e-s and then type in restaurant
or dinner
and see if we can get some images of
this menu no not the menu just let's
take a look at the restaurant
put up images images oh oh darling oh my
god this is the restaurant right here
okay everything the price the menu
whatever it is it's in euros
it does and it's it it was
she's like we're going to this place i
don't care it's the
i only want to go there because it's the
fanciest most expensive place in all of
paris there's lauren there's lauren
no
500 later wow for dinner is that is this
it you can confirm that this is the
place that's the place yes of course the
red couches that's it outdoor it's
gorgeous don't get me wrong it's a
beautiful place but
it was
the experience turned to just be
annoying as hell there's adam and it was
it was just not worth it in the end
i've had dates where we just go to like
very romantic inside yeah it was just it
was all about the excessiveness
okay and it it was just like
it just felt
too much
i'm like babe whatever you want to get
you get that's fine i know i'm getting
about to get hit for 500 bucks just get
it i don't ask for chicken fingers but
but like let's
it just
something was off is all i'm saying it
was for her
like it was more about let's spend as
much money as possible at the most gaudy
place possible yeah rather than enjoying
each other's company okay i'll give you
a flip side there's another girl i dated
like another girl anyway we used to go
to dinner
local sushi place moshi moshi love the
place
moshimoshi yeah shout out to nancy tran
that's a trans shadow the bill is maybe
a hundred bucks maybe
but the place is awesome we're enjoying
each other's company we're having a good
time we're not getting whacked by salt
bay spending 850 bucks there's no guy
pouring salt on us exactly so it's it
really is about
like
spending as much money as possible
eating at the fanciest place is not what
it's all about it's actually about the
company you're with and enjoying the
company you're with and yeah the food is
a bonus okay that's where i'm at with
this i gotcha where are you so it was
well that's the thing so
and during this relationship that i was
in there was this thing where like we we
liked just on purpose like seeing what
is the priciest restaurant in our area
and let's go try it out not because like
oh because we can because we couldn't we
knew we couldn't but it was just like
that like okay how good is this place
really it turned out they would always
be i got one comment right here silly
white boy love that name says i have
good memories a dollar drink night at
applebee's
okay
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke